[Música]
sou o filho caçula de cinco irmãos
é a minha família veio do piauí
assim como várias famílias vieram do
estado de são paulo pra atrás de uma
vida melhor né
é desde muito cedo eu fui muito
influenciado pela música e lembro que na
época da escola né
a creche e vamos dizer assim foi uma
época que eu comecei a conviver em
coletivo né
e foi essa época que eu comecei a notar
comigo mesmo que eu tinha uma certa
dificuldade dificuldade em me comunicar
com as pessoas dificuldade em falar eu
era muito gago pode não parecer agora eu
ainda sou gago só que na época da escola
foi muito mais complicado assim como o
assunto é bullying né que é que estão
falando eu também sofri esse bullying só
que eu não eu conseguia lidar muito bem
com isso porque eu dava risada junto com
os jovens que queriam me atacar
então eu conseguia lidar muito bem com
isso mas o problema real era comigo
mesmo como que eu lidava com tudo aquilo
dentro de mim eu evitava a ter contato
com as pessoas
eu evitava o máximo ser o centro das
atenções assim como eu estou sendo agora
isso seria era um terror pra mim meu
medo era professora de português nada
contra os professores de português é uma
língua portuguesa mas as professoras
naquela época não sei se ainda é assim o
sistema de ensino acredito que seja ela
elas pediam para que os alunos lêem em
voz alta para toda a classe aquilo pra
mim juro para vocês é era realmente
desesperador a minhas mãos suavam o meu
coração batia forte eu queria faltar da
aula dela eu eu inventava que queria ir
no banheiro eu eu tentava todas as
formas para mim não ter que passar por
essa situação
então assim é e devido a isso eu lembro
que também na aula
de educação física eu ficava em uma
quadra sozinho jogando basquete com uma
bola murcha
enquanto todos os meninos jogavam
futebol eu automaticamente eu me excluir
do convívio dos né como os demais alunos
devido a essa minha falta de comunicação
mas isso num ponto foi ao meu ver hoje
foi muito bom para mim porque porque eu
desenvolvi uma opinião muito própria
por eu ser um jovem quieto calado
eu desenvolvi uma uma opinião própria eu
não é eu não era maria vai com as outras
sabe o que enquanto eles iam fazer tal
coisa eu falava não eu vou fazer isso
tanto que eu ficava sozinho jogando
basquete o meu primeiro emprego foi na
guarda mirim de tatuí bom é essa fase
foi muito complicado para mim porque eu
era obrigado a abordar motoristas né
o motorista que possui na maioria das
vezes não queria nem dá atenção pra mim
né porque tinha que pagar o
estacionamento e tal então assim o cara
que me ensinou a trabalhar ele me
ensinou que eu tinha que dar
bater continência para o motorista certo
aí nesse ato de bater continência era o
impulso que eu tinha pra minha voz a
yoki legal
aí eu usei essa técnica não só no meu
trabalho como na minha vida inteira não
terá hoje eu já não uso mais mas assim é
bom eu não saía de relógio na rua para
não correr o risco de alguém parar e
perguntar hora pra mim eu ficar
gaguejando na frente da pessoa
hoje só de raiva humana que esse relógio
gigante no braço quem quiser perguntar
hora eu falo sem problemas e rio porque
eu me reprimia muito com isso
é eu lembro que as minhas dificuldades
eram pra falar palavras com p&d e ip
as palavras de explosão assim né então
quando eu tinha que chamar algum amigo
meu na casa poxa daniel daniel eu
chegava não conseguia falar
então eu batia palmas era mais fácil né
o jeito então assim é mais um fator
importante para mim foi a música que o
gago eu não sei se tem alguém que pegar
o conhece gago o gago pra cantar ele
canta muito bem canta muito bem só que
no meu caso por eu ser um jovem muito
reprimido muito retraído muito tímido
até eu eu eu tinha uma uma visão de
mundo que era diferente das outras
pessoas é dos meus colegas e tal então
eu sentia uma vontade enorme de me
expressar muito grande então assim
poxa quero cantar jogava basquete e o
basquete me levou ao rap ritmo e poesia
me identifiquei muito com esse segmento
musical e foi através desse segmento que
eu comecei a digamos assim foi uma
válvula de escape vamos dizer assim
porque toda pessoa nós somos uma uma
panela de pressão é o que eu falo é o
ser humano é uma bomba preparada para
explodir mas porque eu não explodi igual
vários alunos que que sofreram bullying
e explode
por que ao invés de usar uma arma e
matar todo mundo que me atacava né com o
bullying eu usei uma arma que é papel ea
caneta eu canalizei todo esse meu ódio e
visão de mundo da música
certo legal tinha um monte de letra com
15 anos de idade fazendo música mas e
subir no palco para cantar anjo que medo
como o que seria isso porque eu sabia
que não era só pegar o microfone e
cantar eu tinha que me comunicar com as
pessoas eu tinha que falar com as
pessoas e aí que estava o meu problema
mas mesmo assim parece que eu sinto que
a minha vontade de me expressar era
muito maior do que o meu medo de passar
vergonha de ser motivo de chacota e não
perdia a oportunidade nenhuma de subir
no palco e com isso eu comecei a ver que
a gagueira ela é ela é ela é algo
rítmica até porque eu lembro que eu e
até compra pão por exemplo balcão era
ali eu ensaiava um dois três das cinco
pães
sabe eu dava uns passos então até esse
meu tapa
a perna eu lembrava puxa é rítmico sabe
tem ritmo então o gago ele tem uma
facilidade para cantar por incrível que
pareça né então então sim eu vi que isso
me ajudou muito bom o que eu posso dizer
eu era um gago que queria cantar cantar
rap é é assim pra mim chegar nesse ponto
de subir no palco está dialogando
fazendo shows né
foi um processo muito árido e grande é
quando eu comecei é eu busquei usar usar
a fazer bom uso das ferramentas que eu
tinha disponíveis para mim na época eu
tinha um sonho meio louco uma meta na
verdade quando eu comecei a cantar a
subir no palco e depois acho que eu levo
jeito para essa coisa e eu estou
gostando as pessoas estão gostando
então eu tô vendo que eu tô eu posso
levar a sério é a música na minha vida
em diferentes eu ia ganhar dinheiro ou
não né eu acho que o bem que a música
feita pra mim vale muito mais do que
qualquer quantia em dinheiro é então
então assim eu eu estabeleci uma meta um
sonho um sonho que eu carrego até hoje
eu queria dar a volta no mundo gravando
com outros rappers e produtores de
outros países porque eu sei que o rep
ele está presente em todos os lugares do
planeta não é uma cultura que é está só
em um lugar
então assim através da internet o meu
computador zinho velho com a internet
discada o meu inglesinho básico ali eu
comecei a entrar em contato com
produtores de outros países eu tinha
esse sonho mas poxa eu não tinha
dinheiro nem pra ir pra uma cidade
vizinha como eu ia sair como que eu ia
para outro país não tinha como assim
como eu tenho até agora mas é eu busquei
usará as poucas ferramentas que eu tinha
na época e comecei a entrar em contato
com as pessoas para né mandando
mensagens para uma mensagem pra outro e
tal até que começaram a me responder
olha eu também faço música já estava
gravando ali na minha casa e tal e falei
poxa é o que puxa vamos gravar vão
produzir música junto você cantando em
inglês eu cantando em português né
e consegui fazer a minha primeira música
com parceria internacional e atravessa
música veio vindo esse processo é um
processo meio longo porque eu venho
fazendo música com pessoas de fora do
brasil há mais ou menos uns 15 anos já
então assim olhando pra mim hoje é eu já
gravei com gente importantíssimas no
cenário é do rap mundial e também é
entende que não existe barreira pra
música a música é uma linguagem
universal
ela é uma linguagem que quebra essa
barreira dos idiomas e eu comecei a ver
que eu ainda não pude estar presente
nesses países mas a minha voz está lá
a voz que eu tanto retraía voz que eu
tanto evitava de mostrar ela chegou até
lá então assim vale a pena você encarar
os seus medos muito a pena
o que que o rep me ensinou eu mais
ganhei como é com o rap do que do que
doei né porque assim o rap é um segmento
musical que tem muito a ver com a
realidade da periferia
eu por ser jovem de periferia cresci em
meio à criminalidade nunca fui envolvido
mas vi pessoas se perdendo nesse meio
e por que que eu escolhi a fazer rap
porque eu queria me expressar a fazer
música mas não música à toa
eu queria é é passar informação real na
música infelizmente não foi à escola não
foi esse sistema escolar que me fez ter
interesse em adquirir conhecimento em
abril um livro para ler em em busca
informação foi o rap que me deu essa
necessidade cara você precisa aprender
você precisa buscar informação porque é
da informação que você vai conseguir
escrever letra
então é eu o rap me obrigou a fazer isso
a abrir livros e lê e me posicionar
entende em e em mostrar porque eu falar
é falar de deus dentro de uma igreja é
muito fácil falar de rap para pessoas
que haja poxa
pepe é coisa de bandido rep então a
gente sofre essa estigma
vivemos na capital da música também
subiu no palco aqui na cidade demorou
muito porque a automaticamente já tinha
aquele pré-conceito a se canta rap
tinham medo de dar o microfone na minha
mão e eu falar coisa desnecessária mas
eu tinha coerência naquilo que eu falava
eu tinha total cuidado naquilo que eu
falava mas mesmo assim foi um processo
muito longo até que chegamos a esse
ponto 2012 fizemos um evento dentro do
conservatório onde eu fui o primeiro
rapper a se apresentar dentro do
conservatório só que eu não queria
cantar eu eo meu dj e meu amigo que é
backing vocal comigo não eu queria fazer
algo a mais eu sempre fui um moleque
meio com a visão à frente eu queria
juntar um quarteto de cordas né
é música erudita com o dj e os toca
discos e mais as minhas rimas as minhas
músicas e foi fenomenal foi foi foi foi
algo realmente inusitado
bom o que mais o rap foi em que mais um
rap foi importante pra mim eu uso a
cultura hip hop como ferramenta de
mudança o que eu aprendi o que eu sou
hoje eu devo muito a esse segmento
musical
então assim eu comecei a entender que é
e eu preciso fazer música mas eu preciso
fazer com que a mensagem seja entendida
pelas pessoas
só que eu vi aqui a música ainda é
limitado eu posso falar uma coisa mas as
pessoas precisam entender o que eu tô
falando existe filtros mentais e cada
pessoa então eu vi que não a música tá
indo até o limite
depois disso eu falei poxa eu tenho que
está presente com esses jovens com essas
pessoas que eu quero atingir foi aí que
surgiu a oportunidade de estar fazendo
projetos sociais
néné e mikhail a oportunidade de está
trabalhando com com a com menores
infratores a gente começou fazendo o
evento nas escolas isso em 2006 e
começamos a desenvolver
fomentar a cultura hip hop dentro da
cidade poxa através do grafite néné
dança esporte tal e várias outras coisas
hoje eu tenho um projeto chamado rimas e
batidas e consciência onde eu levo
equipamentos né pra esses jovens essa
oficina é aberta não é só para menores
infratores e ali o ensino o jovem a
produzir as músicas criar o conteúdo a
gente faz a gente faz eventos então
assim a música foi muito importante pra
mim então eu tento passar isso pra esses
jovens que são jovens que não são
assistidos que na maioria das vezes são
jovens que poxa ninguém espera nada
deles o porquê são pretos ou porque são
pobres ou porque moram em bairros onde o
crime do meia então não espero que saia
nada dali mas eu comecei a ver que ali
tem muito diamante que vem da lama né
vamos de som pode ser
[Música]
mas o menino filho de pais nordestinos
que não sabia o meu destino mal me
comunicar vá às vezes aprontava mas sim
a respeito pelo que minha mãe falava
jogando basquete no país do futebol
desde muito cedo busquei meu espaço ao
sol e escutando rap nas fitas cassetes
hum
o tempo bom que não se repete foi
trabalhar sem reclamar
mesmo ganhando pouco sabia valorizar
comecei a me questionar muito cedo fui
obrigado a encarar meu próprio medo o
dago resolveu se expressar não consegue
nem falar e ainda quer cantar sem medo
de ser zoado e com muito pra falar eu
encontrei no rap meu caminho para
trilhar
agradeço a deus agradeço a vida agradeço
a qualquer um que ainda acredita que
tudo pode ser multado
muito obrigado esse é meu recado
[Música]
[Aplausos]